[音楽]
ムートン
どんな人生がいい人生なのでしょうか
いったい誰に評価されればいい人生だったと言えるのでしょうか
今日私が話したいのは人生をどうやって払うか
その物差しについてです身長はセンチメートル体重はキログラム
人生はどうやって測ればいいのでしょうか
寿命でしょうか平均年収でしょうか
友達の数ローワーの数結婚してるかしてないか
子供がいるかいないか世の中にいろんな
尺度がかかり方が物差しがあります
あなたにとって一番大事な物差し
尺度は何でしょうか
私は昔からすごい人いないからです
すごい人になればすごい人生なのではないかと思っていました
中学生の時高校生の時これができればすごい人なんじゃないかと思う
ものさし尺度が3つありました
スポーツができる勉強ができるをていっ
この3つのうちどれかができれば自分はいい人生を送ってすごい人なんだと思うことが
できるっ
と思っています
その時の自分にとって省職業とか
年習得将来どうなるとかそんなことはどうでもよかったです
集光性の私にとって人生の価値というのは
そんなたいそういたものではなくただただこの3つ
勉強ができるスポーツができるモデル
だけでしっ
まず私は鏡を見てこれはモテないと思い
オルサ歯を1本打てました
残るは勉強かスポーツああということでスポーツをめちゃくちゃ頑張りました
でもどうやってもどう頑張っても全然スポーツがうまくならなかったので勉強に
取り組むことあるしました
the 勉強ださあ一橋大学だということで一橋大学を受験し結局
浪人することになったんですが運良く合格して私は跳ねて勉強ができる人になって行っ
たらすごい人に慣れたと思うようになりました
ただその喜びはつかの間でしてい
なぜなら一橋大学に足を踏み入れた瞬間
気づいてしまったんです
周りが全員一橋生であること
一橋の中に入った途端に全員合格し全員一つ
という現実を目の当たりにして
一瞬で私はすごい人ではなくただ普通の人ということに気づいてしまいます
それが大きなショックとなりました
大学生になった私はもう一度鏡を見てこれもこれはまた持てないということを再認識し
じゃあ次はスポーツだということで大学からまだ大学彼の前にあと誘ってくれた
冒頭部入部することにしました
めちゃくちゃ頑張って幸いにも u 23アンダー23世界選手権日本代表に選ばれて
準優勝することができたり
一橋のチームとしても定額4位
何十年ぶりの快挙を成し遂げることができました
卒業後もうボートを続けてい大手じゃねーよオリンピック
2016年に出場することができました
非常にこれも嬉しかったです
スポーツができるようになったすごい人になれたん
特にオリンピックの出場方を決めてある武器は決まったときは本当にうれしかったこと
を今でも覚えています
ですがこの喜びもまた束の間でした
オリンピックの結団式だったり走行会だったりいろんなオリンピック選手が集まる
ところに
一歩踏み入れた瞬間にそれは実房でした
メダルを
期待されている選手もいれば金メダルを期待されている選手
そして3連覇4連覇連覇を期待されて選手がいる中で私はただの
出場喜んで生主
手に次なかったんです
これは本当に大きな勝負ですね
すごい人になる
そのために勉強やらスポーツある頑張ってきましたがすごい人になったとしても上には
上がいてすごい人になるというのは a に難しいように思いました
もう金メダルを目指すしかすごい人になることはできないと思い
東京オリンピックでは金メダルを目指しましたが国内選考に通過することもできず敗退
しました
私は私のものさし人生の意味価値について限界を感じていました
今思えばそのショックの解決策として
金メダルは得策ではないことをすでに自分で理解していたのかもしれません
私はボート競技を引退しましたん
半年ほど悩んで私は何をしたかったんだろうかと非常に考えました
私がすごい人だと認定していた人は決して単に勉強ができる人単にスポーツができる人
ではなかっ
私が本当にすごい人だと思っている人は
初めてのことを誰もやったことないことを自分ができると信じて努力してやり遂げる人
だったんです
誰もやったことないことを意思の力努力の力で叶える1
高校生の時中学生
それを表現するためには
スポーツか勉強しかありませんん
勉強した理由も
私の出身高校からは一橋大学という難関大学に志願する1号覚醒人はほとんどいなかっ
た
betta になる数年1人いるかいないか
スポーツを頑張った理由もそうです一橋大学で日本スポーツで日本一になる
オリンピックにデー
そういう誰も成し遂げてない
ほとんど誰もやったことないことを自分はできると新してやり遂げたいそういう気持ち
があったからこそ
頑張れたんだと思います
私は決して一番になりたいわけではなく
1人目になりたかっ
すごい人っていうのは一番の人で一番だからすごいのではなくて誰もやったことない
ことをやった人をすごい人だと思う
自分がそこにいたんです自分だけはできると信じてそれを叶えるそれが私の価値観で
あり
趣味であり
自分自身のすごい人の定義などだと気づきました
一方で同時に気づいたことがあります
いつまにか私は他人から評価されることを喜びに感じる
社会的にすごい人になろうとしています
オリンピックに出てたくさんの人に祝福してもらいました
それが嬉しくてもっともっと祝福されたいもっとモップ他人から喜ばれたいと思うよう
になり
自分の価値観を満たすためではなく他人の価値観を満たすために生きようと思う
自分が生まれてきましたそしてその思いがどんどんどんどん強くなってしまいました
そして自分が結局どんな人間になりたいのかどんな人生を送りたいのかという
八かを見失う結果になってしまいました
社会的評価は行きてーきゅう上ですごく必要なものです
社会的評価がなければいい
豊かに生きていくことはできないと思います
ですがその社会的評価だけを求めて人生というのは霧があります
何時メダルとってもたとえいくら稼いだとして上には上がいる世界が待っているだけだ
と思います
上を見て絶望して下を見てホッとするそんな人間にはなりたくないと思います
私は自分の価値観を大事にしよう
と思うようになりました
私は自分から見てすごい人になりたい
その結果として社会が私をそんな私を認めてくれればそれはすごく嬉しん
でも社会からの評価というのは決して主食になるものではなく
単なるデザートだと思っています
デザートのある人生の最高ですがまず第一として自分が自分を認めてるかそれがあって
からの初めてのデザートだと思っ
中学生の時5号線とき自分で勝手に設定したすごい人になりたくて一生懸命頑張りまし
た運良く目標設定が自分の価値観
手段がマッチしてたので結果が出たのだと思っています
誰もやったことないことを意思の力努力の力で叶える1
それに通じてていたのだと思います
ですが利用リンピックに出場してからはもっと認められたいと社会のものさしの中で
自分を大きくしたくて
東京オリンピックを目指す自分になってしまいました
社会が定義するすごい人と自分が定義する
すごい人というのは違っていたということです
日本の社会にはその人の価値を決める物差しがたくさんあります
小学校だったのドッチボールが強いだとかけ
早いとか結構速いやつ
社会人になった今では年収だとか職業
いろんな尺度があります
その尺度を持って人はこの人は大物だとか
そこまで大物じゃないと
判断していると思います
ですが最も大事な評価は自分が自分に対して自分の人生を認めてるいるかどうか
だと思っています
自分が何歳になっても変わらない自分の価値か自分の人生を模写し
を
正確に評価出来ていれば
まず自分はいい人生を送れ送っていると思えるのではないでしょうか
今思えばオリンピックに出た時
たくさんの人に出場ベルトと祝福されてうれしかったんですけども
もっともうれしかったことは
自分を信じたねとかやり遂げだねという言葉です
私はオリンピック出場を目標に頑張っていましたが実際やりたかったのは自分を信じる
ことだったんだか
やり遂げることだったんだな今となってはいます
今の私は社会の物差しているとそんなに優等生じゃありません
むしろ劣等生だと思います
練習もそこまで高くないですし潮低いですし
社会的責任があるのかといえばない方だと思います
ですが自分の物差しが初めての人間であることだ
ということに気付けた今はそれに向かって一生懸命頑張ろうと思っています
結果的に
成功して結果的に社会の人な私を評価してくれればそれはそれで嬉しいですし
評価されても評価されなくても自分の人生に対して満足いく結果になるのではないかな
と思います
社会の評価をれた事が
充実した人生なのではなく
自分が
なりたい自分になれたことが充実した人生の定義だと思っています
長くなりますすごく長くなりました
要約すると私にとってのいいいい
は何でしょうかということです
あなたにとって色んな sns
文書画像動画
いろんな
投稿に対して活動にたしていいねっというボタンをやりますが
何に対してあなたは良いでを押しているのでしょう
どんな価値どんな価値観どんな人生を
が変わるがいいねと思っていますか
もしそれがわかれば
どれだけ失敗しても挫折しても
くじけても社会がなんです
冷たい風を浴びても
くじけず
突き進んでいけるのではないかと思っていますなぜなら自分が自分もいいと思っている
からです
大事なのは何百の良い音ではなく
自分が自分に対してにねっを持っているかどうかと思います
自分に認められる自分がいいと思う
人生を
毎日一日一日を遅れれば最高です
最高ですねはいっ
以上ありございました